Hey.
Usually when someone comes in front of a red curtain, it is to say that you are going to see something scary
and indeed, with the standard of the internet, you are going to see something very scary tonight:
opinions.
Oh my God!
I know, I know. Sometimes opinions are very scary, especially if they are not yours.
However, think of the first time Nostalgia Critic reviewed It and everyone got very angry
and now everyone wants him to do a Stephen King review once a year.
So, being the internet, we can all be adults and agree that there are better things to argue about.
My fiance said this would happen, so he wrote a spare speech for me.
If any of your whining buggers have a problem with that, then you can fight that out with me!
So that's better,
Enjoy the review, have fun
and remember, if someone feels irritated,
then I will prick you even harder, asshole!
Was 'It' almost
So, I hear that your cinema version breaks all kinds of records.
You know, when mine was on TV, the ratings flew out.
Viewing figures? What are those again?
Success was measured before Netflix arrived
Sounds stupid.
It was that too.
They said no one was looking at Family Guy,
but the fans brought it back so that years later nobody would look at Family Guy.
Well, now measure how far the greenhouse is cracking.
It is only a matter of time before people say that I am "It" definitive.
I was the first to appear in children's nightmares.
The first is the worst, as any comment on YouTube would say.
They are already looking back and remember how cool I was.
I'll tell you your mate. I was almost "it."
No, time will continue and then everyone will remember me.
I was almost "it."
I think I shouldn't be here.
You know, where I come from, we call it "IT audience" instead of "IT audience."
Oh, shut up Moss and tell us who does 'It' better.
Yes come on. I'm scary.
Do you know....
But I'm funnier.
We are not supposed to be funny.
We are damn clowns!
This is even worse than my first episode in America.
Hey guys.
Pour in a vodka martini cupcake and let me participate.
No.
We are not going to do that.
Oh, come on, what's the problem?
You always ruin 'It' for people.
Yes, children were scared of me once,
but now they come to me and do "WA-HA! WA-HA! WA-HA!"
Oh come on, I liked some things in 'It'.
The children were good, you were good.
And?
I don't know, I fainted because of the Stephen King Drinking Game ™.
Oh my god, does that game come with a doctor's warning?
Yes, you see, he does this.
He ruined scary things by pointing out their mistakes.
Like asking why my head turning into a dog had to be scary.
Well, why did it have to be scary?
The "Pound Puppies" took over the recordings.
Forget it, you are not going to ruin our pleasure this time.
Okay listen, you both try to figure out who the final version is.
Is it not logical that I listen to both parties to find out who is better?
Let me decide who 'It' almost was.
No not really.
Horrible idea.
Bad luck, I'm not talking about "The Dark Tower".
Good point.
You know what. Go ahead. Everyone in the world loves my movie.
The president of the critics said, "If Jesus was a movie, then it was this movie."
The United Nations Film Critics said, "Stop making films. Nothing gets better than" It. "
And the holy church of heavenly criticism said, "No, but kill me. I fear you not,
because I have seen 'It' and I know that nothing in life will be better. "
"Going too far," you would say. "Going on a hype", maybe.
I say no.
I challenge you.
I welcome you to find something that is not right in my version of "It."
Okay, this is the cinema version of 'It'.
I hoped you were intimidated by that.
Was not me.
'The'
When the credits run we see a little boy named Georgie and his stuttering brother Bill.
Okay, we exchange it for this dialogue.
New white Bill, you think the SS Georgia is ready to sail.
She certainly is.
They?
You always call a ship a "she".
Even if it's called SS Georgia.
Do you want to go to the real problems of this movie or not?
Yes, then.
He would like to test his paper boat in the rain, but he first has to get something from the scary basement.
Yes, I am sure I will not be killed before the credits expire
and everyone knows that sewer well scene,
so I assume that these are light bulbs.
But you don't have to be so mean about it.
Georgia loses his boat in a sewer pit, where he meets the infamous clown, Pennywise.
Hello Georgie!
No!
Hey wait, where are you going?
Hey wait, where is he going?
No child is attracted by someone who looks so scary.
Yes, they were attracted to him and he's not even scary.
Exactly stupid.
One of the reasons that Pennywise scared people was because it is a good clown.
He was fun and funny so he could trap kids.
This guy can't even lure weird fan art to Tumblr.
Hey, I was really scary. I feed on people's fears.
But you do not feed on their stupidity, something must attract them.
Do I have to lure them, okay?
I have to go.
Oh yes, that worked great.
You know, we should have eaten it right away.
Agree.
Mourning the loss of his brother, Bill gets, over time, a group of rude friends
known as the Token Troop ..
I mean, the Losers Club (Stumpers in NL) ...
I mean...
... let's keep it at Token Club.
It uses many of the traditional child style styles,
but to be honest, it was the origin of this, so there is a little leeway,
like when the Token girl, Bev, befriends the Token fat guy Ben.
So you're the new kid in the street. What are you listening to?
New Kids on the Block.
Really?
Yes really?
Okay, it's the only 80s thing they ram through your throat.
But it's stupid.
Very stupid.
Okay, do you want that or do you want to do what every 80s movie does and therefore wear this?
All right. - We'll take the stupid joke.
Good. Now go back to your romantic kind of relationship.
I think I'll be attracted to you later.
Something like that.
Perhaps.
Kind of.
Strangely enough, the other characters are introduced early by frightening Pennywise,
which is strange since we have to be afraid of that even though we don't know the characters well yet.
Such as Stanley, the Jewish figure.
I wonder why a Jewish temple would have a scary abstract painting of a woman.
Could it be based on that woman there.
I think I'm not going to tell anyone about this.
Yes, I have no jokes for that moment, that was really a scary scene.
Which is a shame, because some moments of shock are ruined because the film does not continue with its ideas.
For example, the fear of fear figure, named Eddie, is looking for his medicine.
A scary-looking hand grabs it and holds it for him.
This is a brilliant approach, keeping the hand in the foreground,
so that the identity of the scary figure remains vague and with that you build up how scary he looks.
This is masterful, but when its appearance is revealed.
I have a cold.
That result is not scary enough, it is just a very sick-looking man.
He must actually be a leper, but come on, you could make it worse than this.
I think this is scary for someone with a fear of stains, but this is not so bad for us.
Shock moments can also be made less in other ways.
The black figure, named Mike, quickly sees a remains from a burned building.
This would be incredibly disturbing if the music once stopped.
Most of the music is very exaggerated.
If it should be pleasant, then the pleasure will continue as if Tinkelbel is being pressed into your ass.
You are wonderful oh so beautiful childhood is fun there is nothing wrong with that
And if it has to be scary, it will be better if it is a little quieter,
but there are not so many quiet moments.
Instead, the shivers that you are supposed to get are transformed into jumpscares that are thrown into your skull.
Listen, just like any soundtrack, a scary soundtrack is essential,
but if it is used too often, it can become just like a smile band
where it is pushed through someone's throat while coming naturally.
Let's do this scene again, but we dim the music a lot
and focus more on scary silence and some well-chosen sound effects.
Didn't that seem creepier? Even the passing car wasn't much more spectacular.
Don't get me wrong, some moments of shock work very well.
Like the burnt, decapitated mind, its revelation and its movements are scary.
But, I have to admit it is a bit stupid when you see that it is still Pennywise.
Hold on, what do you mean by "stupid"? There is nothing stupid about me.
I'm the scariest thing on film.
Do you want to tell him or will I do it?
I think we should both tell him.
What, tell me what?
You are a clown!
Regardless of what you do, you always remain a bit stupid.
Just embrace it, you denying idiot.
That is not true! Do you remember that I am the ..
I mean Billy, frightened with his dead brother?
Look, I'm Jeff Dunham if he'd have been funny.
Well come on, that's scary right?
Yes, but it's kind of funny too.
I'm not supposed to be funny.
I get very scary when I run to him like that.
What is that?
That's my thing, my frightening way of running.
You look and sound like a possessed version of Olaf from 'Frozen'.
Go make 'Ferngully' scary again, this is scary.
Oh my god, I'll play Benny Hill's music on this.
Oh my god, do that.
This is scary!
Oh, that's gold.
This was never funny until I met you.
There's a kid in the movie, I swear, he's in his own movie, and that's Richie.
I think this kid is great, mainly because he is a nerd-like variant of Ash. Think about it.
He has all one-liners.
They say Derry is full of beaver traps
And that is it. Still guys!
Except if he doesn't have it.
Something, something, something your mother. Still guys!
He is super cowardly.
I don't want to go in there.
Except if he isn't.
Do you see this? This is my bat!
He is, oddly enough, the nastiest and coolest kid in the entire film, the constant contradiction.
Nerd on
But other conflicting things are more distracting than fun.
Like the adults who don't see the blood while the child does, it is stranger in this.
Have you done anything to your hair?
I'm going to do some scary things there.
But then the children clear the blood while dancing to an 80s song.
The swinging blood cleaning scene?
Why don't you immediately add a whisk like in a girl's film.
See, you have no idea what you are doing.
Well, our version, by contrast, we made balloons scary.
No you did not. -A little?
Not a little bit. -Ienie-mini?
Stop now. -All right then.
The new film did, on the other hand, do.
What?!
First, all balloons are red, so they stand out more and serve as an ominous sign.
I bet that when people see red balloons, they'll think about 'It' for a long time.
Second, they are used to reveal something. There is always something behind the balloon.
The balloon itself is not scary, but more a build-up for the actual shock that is coming.
So when we see it, we get scared.
I even think the bullies are a lot better.
Yes, the ultimate overall Stephen King troop is actually quite well done here,
especially the leader, Henry, who not only has an understandable background,
but they also make it clear that his harassment is more disturbed than most other bullying.
It is not just standard, but they also say that it is quite disturbed.
I've been waiting for you outside the library all the time, Ben.
You had been waiting for hours and knew that I would come this way.
How dare you pinpoint my cinematic mistakes. Only for that ...
Oh my god, why are you dealing with him?
To be honest, we are hiding behind you.
Yes, we are afraid he will cut us.
Hey, it works.
But Ben manages to escape and runs into the Stumperds who look after his wounds.
Ask your. Why didn't we take him to a hospital?
Oh, me. Well, that's because the adults in the neighborhood don't care about the kids.
Okay, I know that, because I read the book. But outside of a couple who drive by in their car, that is not made clear.
Yes and even then people still live. They must have something of a medical building.
No time for that. Billy sees Bev walking for the first time in slow-mo.
Wait, didn't he just see her in the pharmacy?
But not in slow-mo.
But is that not usually used when you see someone for the first time?
Like when you see her first, are things slower? Why do you only do that later?
Is it "love at second sight"?
What? You don't know that.
Indeed, we do not know that.
If you don't know, I won't tell you either.
Who won it?
So Ben invites the Stumpers as a token of thanks for saving him.
Yes, I study disappearances and history of the villages I have just moved to.
Wow, your incredibly specific hobby suits us well.
I will give this to the film instead of letting the fat man be obsessed with:
Food!
Here he is obsessed with ...
Village!
It is a bit forced, but not as forced as this.
Oh my god, do you still like New Kids on the Block?
Yes, as clearly stated earlier.
Wow, that's so 80s.
Hey, someone else has noticed this incredibly clear photo of a clown with the city's founders.
I mean, we have to pause the whole movie to watch that poster.
While we also play a song about it.
I mean, he's hanging here so everyone can see him. I thought someone would notice.
Yes, this film is mostly timeless, but sometimes we have to kick you in with the 80s.
Yes, because we have only had five close-ups of the poster.
And only two of the scary clown here. Let someone else notice. Let someone else notice.
Did I mention that "Batman" and "Lethal Weapon" are in the cinema?
Wow, the 80s are so cool.
Let us never refer to it again.
Clown.
Shut up Richie!
The tone gets crazier when Mike reappears in the film.
Yes, he had disappeared for quite a while, right?
I feel a little self-defeated.
There is only one thing we can do for this serious scene where we fight our fears.
Weird music and slow-mo.
You tru ...
Weirdly directing.
Do you remember when this was a serious and important scene?
Yes, now it's silly and stupid!
Did you see that? It didn't even hurt. I'm just a cartoon.
So they save Mike and decide to admit him to the Stumpers.
Do you believe in UFOs, mental projections, mental telepathy, ESP, clairvoyance
ghost photography, telekinetic movements, complete transmediums, the Loch Ness monster and the theory of Atlantis.
As long as I'm not being pushed away like that Jewish boy, I believe everything you say.
Which Jewish boy?
Shalom!
Oh yes, Stanley.
You had certainly forgotten that I was a character?
It's all right, it's all right.
There are so many characters in this film that someone would get less time in the picture anyway.
In fact, I'm not there for half the time, then I'm a cardboard doll.
I didn't even know that.
That what do you think Mike? Do you want to join the club?
Okay, where do you want me?
Jewish boy in the back.
The movie becomes really nice again and not forced like,
You tru ...
.. whatever that may be.
After a scene where Pennywise comes to life in a projector, the kids go into a haunted house that
Frankly, it's like a haunted house in your neighborhood during Halloween and I mean that in a good way.
There are rooms with scary toys, cobwebs, doors that lead to moments of shock. It's fun, bloody fun.
Do not say that!
Don't say what?
Things like "fun, bloody pleasure." Does this sound like a voice that does "nice, bloody pleasure"?
I'm super scary and super serious in this creepy review of "It."
I change my body into all sorts of sharp things.
Oh, you mean by your bad digital effects.
Oh, that's really typical of your critics, isn't it?
I had completely forgotten that he was there.
Yes, you were not just for a nice opening.
I know how this works.
If you identify bad digital effects, that means that you hate all digital effects.
That is not at all what I said, but ..
I get it. You hate Pixar, you despise Jurassic Park,
You want to see Agent Hopps die.
Okay listen, digital effects are great and have come a long way, especially in horror movies.
CGI can make a ghost look like it is there and it isn't at the same time.
It is one of the few examples where secrecy really helps an effect
and it works well in this movie for half the time.
The scary painting that comes to life, the boy without a head. More than the hell of digital effects are very effective.
Great, that means you love all CGI. I'm glad we made that clear.
No, that's right. Just like all effects, there are good and bad ones
and when you use them so often in your film, the bad ones are more noticeable.
The fear of Pennywise is not that he is a transparent mind, he must really be there
and if your digital effects don't have the time to make it look like his hand turns into a werewolf or a monster,
because you had to use that time on other digital effects, fear is considerably reduced.
No, it was all great and you hate everything that is digital.
Like that blurry run effect. How did you do that?
Oh, of course.
You just filmed your face very close on the phone.
It costs thousands of CGI artists to copy this.
Are we still playing?
The children fight back against Pennywise, showing that they can beat him,
so of course this is the moment that they separate and each choose their own way.
See you soon, this is the moment that we separate and each choose our own way.
Oh yes, you really caught me there film.
I am sure they will never see each other again.
No, it's very sad.
Oh yes, too bad you never get together again.
Wait, why are we leaving anyway? He's on the run, we can finish him.
No no. This is the part where you retire.
But that cliché is in everything. I know, I was in those clichés when they became popular.
We are not going to repair old clichés. We will add more instead.
Like which?
Well, the lady in need, to begin with.
Followed by the kiss of a true love to break the curse.
Are you serious?
Well, the graph says ...
Shall we go to a graphics bar, maybe talk about math.
Let's look at the graph. -Yes.
So the Stumpers come together to save Beverly.
She's down there.
Wait, what's that on your arm?
That is plaster.
Did you go to a hospital? I thought I knew you.
You'll all be going to the hospital soon.
Quick, Mike.
Damn Mike, we want you to sort of finish your story now.
Oh okay.
I had a reason to be here!
Awesome! Now I can tell you about my incredibly interesting background.
Uh, we're actually a little past two o'clock.
We may be able to give you a bonus component on the Blu-ray.
Good enough.
Really, a hospital?
The sisters were probably delicious.
I thought it was a placebo!
Meanwhile, Beverly wakes up in the sewer, where ...
Oh, Christ.
What now?
Are you sure you're not supposed to be funny?
What, it's a scary dance of evil. You put it in your pants.
Yes, especially if you play this over it.
Hey, stop it! Stop that!
Oh come on, people just stopped playing 'Gangam Style' about it.
Oh yeah. Well here is something in my version of the film that your version didn't have.
People who really float (through the air).
Oh my god, really?
Yes, that's a very good point. For all those times you said "They float, they always float",
we never see anyone floating in your version.
That won't work. -Yes.
But okay, yes actually.
Sorry, he's a good clown.
They save Beverly, but she is hypnotized. So, as said before,
Ben uses the "kiss of true love" to free her.
You know what, I'm married. I love my wife.
That counts too.
You won't get away that easily.
So Pennywise tries to change all their fears.
Oh, hi kids.
You are just wimps.
The children confront their fears and defeat Pennywise, making them agree that they will return if he ever returns.
I think we succeeded. - That's true.
Ho, I'm sorry, what are you doing?
Kiss you.
Oh, uh, I think I have a better relationship with Ben.
I mean, he saved me, he writes poems for me.
Moreover, I just had a kiss scene with him.
Yes, get rid of my maybe girlfriend.
I'm not following this, it's the last scene of the movie.
Are we really going to end up with a half-baked relationship?
Well, let's see what the book says.
That is a good idea. That is where Beverly ends.
Yes I don't.
Super uncomfortable.
Uh, what do you think if we just do kiss hands?
'The'
And that's the best thing we've ever made as humans.
Cinematic flawless, spooky scary,
the greatest horror movie ever good super yes ... good.
Don't you think you're exaggerating it a little bit?
No, it's perfect and everyone who thinks otherwise hates movies.
Well...
Yes, film hater?
You can't say this is an "error-free" horror movie,
but, at the same time, you can't say he's bad either.
There are many shock effects, fun ideas, good characters
and, with all due respect, it is better than the original.
Generally I recommend it as a scary movie.
Deal with it, Ronald Horror Picture Show!
However, there is something that the original has and the new does not.
What then?
Personality.
The original was silly and strange, but it enjoyed it.
From weird effects, to excessive acting, to bizarre writing
and, of course, Tim Curry who gives a million percent.
It's not scary, but it's an over-the-top, fun TV movie.
This is trying an 80s movie, a timeless movie,
have subtle shock moments, exaggerated moments of shock,
adult humor,
the tone and style are everywhere and nowhere.
I admire that they have tried so much, but that does not always fit together, so that it has less identity of its own.
So, even if the cinema version is better, I will remember the original better.
So yes, it's good enough. I just don't think it's the game-maker that is built up so much by everyone.
But wait, you never answered the question. Which of us 'It' definitely.
Yes, scary or funny? Which one is it'?
Well, I'm probably not the right person to answer that, but I know someone who is.
You both!
Do you know how many incarnations there are of the Joker? Tons!
And do you know what the best have in common?
They are not Jared Leto?
Yes.
And they were both scary and funny.
Don't choose one, be it both.
As the world's most famous killer clown, I would say,
it's best to stop yelling and laughing.
Hey, wasn't I supposed to get your role?
Ho, gotta go.
Would you really get his role.
Yes and I almost had 'It'.
You know, overall, this review is very confusing.
That is your film in a nutshell.
Good point.
That's all people!
What are you looking at?
'The'.
What is it'?
That is the name of the film.
What?
'The'!
What is it'?
It is it'?
And what is that?
'The'!
So is that?
And that's it.
And what is that?
'The'!
So it's it?
Is that not it?
How should I know that?
Because if it wasn't, it could be something else, wouldn't it?
That is it?
Exactly.
And you watch it with them.
No, is they a completely different film?
What are you, a kind of clown?
No, "It" is the clown.
What?
"It," retort it.
Okay, we'll start again. It is like this..
Let's not get John Carpenter.
I do not believe it.
That is your problem. You can't see 'It' if you don't believe it.
It drives me crazy!
Well, that's what 'Het' does.
"It" drives people crazy?
Now you get it.
You dirty, dirty bastard ....
What's the problem?
I would like to know!
Good night people.
Hello, Doug Walker here with this week's charity
and that is now the American Foundation for Suicide Prevention.
This foundation tries to save lives and bring hope to people who have had suicide.
They create a culture that deals with mental health through education social actions,
develop suicide prevention through research and advocacy
and support those who have had suicide.
Headquartered in New York, they have 80 local departments with programs and events throughout the US.
They work hard to raise awareness, raise money, conduct research and provide resources and help those who have been involved with it.
You can go to their site or YouTube channel, there you can see people who have been helped in the past,
who are now being helped and how you can help.
Click on the link below and show how valuable and important life is.